The general good experience,
so
for you,
you had this traumatic experience of
violence when you were young,
you were depressed,
you were trying to figure out what the
source of this was,
whether it was some sort of a chemical
imbalance in your brain.
Now when they say chemical imbalances in
the brain have,
are they capable of measuring the level
of Serotonin in your brain?
Yes,
so there's a huge debate about this.
She couldn't,
for example,
do autopsies and there's a big debate
about,
but that's when someone's dead.
Yeah,
but there's a big debate about.
So there seems to be most scientists
agree,
not all of them,
and there are some people who dissent
from this,
but most scientists agree low serotonin
correlates with depression,
right?
But it's not the same thing in the same
way stretch marks correlate with
obesity,
but they're not the cause of obesity is
that the product to them?
So there are real brain changes that
happen,
which I write about in Los Connections
and important to say that,
that I don't think they should be
described as chemical imbalances,
but one of these,
it was really shocking to me,
was one of the British experts and they
stopped to.
David Healey said to me,
and you can't even say the sorry,
the idea that depression causes serotide
in.
You can't even say that that theory is
discredited because it was never
credited.
There was never a time when half of the
scientists in the field believe that.
Right?
The reason that story got sold to me and
most people listening to this in the
nineties,
it's because it worked really well for
the drug companies,
right?
Because what it makes it sound like if
you've just got a chemical imbalance,
the solution is just to give you
chemicals.
And that's important to say chemical
antidepressants do play a role.
We can measure that.
And there's a slightly nuanced point to
make about this,
which is.
So depression is measured by something
called the Hamilton.
Right.
I've always felt sorry for whoever
Hamilton was that the only way we
remember him is by how fucking miserable
we all.
But anyway,
so how is the scale goes from one where
you are,
you know,
dancing around in ecstasy,
ecstasy.
It's a 51 when you would be acutely
suicidal.
Right?
And to give you a sense of what movement
on the Hamilton scale looks like.
If you move six points on the Hamilton
scale,
sorry.
If your sleep patterns get better,
you'll gain six points on the Hamilton
scale and if your sleep patterns
deteriorate.
So you have a baby who's crying all the
time,
you're generally lose six points on the
Hamilton scale,
right?
So professor Irving Kirsch at Harvard
medical school to the best research on
this,
and what he found is on average chemical
antidepressants move people one point
eight points on the Hamilton scale,
right,
about a third of what improving your
sleep patterns does.
It's important to say that's an average.
So some people do get more than that.
Some people get less and you can say one
point eight points is not nothing,
right?
If you're acutely suicidal,
one point eight points can take the edge
off.
There's real value in giving people that
relief,
but it's not solving the problem for
most people.
I thought I was weird for being on
antidepressants for so long and
remaining depressed.
Turns out I was totally typical concert.
Dr Steve [inaudible] is professor of
psychology,
has done a lot of work on this.
Between 65 and 80 percent of people
taking chemical entity precedence become
depressed.
Again,
this is a guy who is a real Bernie
sanders supporter,
open Bernie Sanders supporter who worked
for the DNC.
The DNC absolutely rigged the primary
against Bernie Sanders.
He was aware of this.
He was there while this was all going
down.
So is Donna Brazil.
Everyone was aware of it.
The guy got fucking murdered after he
leaked information to wikileaks.
If you don't think that's a little
weird,
what are you looking at?
What?
What delusional rose colored glasses.
Are you looking at your party from a.
You think you're in some Julia Roberts
movie from Nineteen Ninety.
This is real shit.
Some guy got killed.
He was 24 years old.
He was a young guy who was very
optimistic and have this view of the
world where he means the guy fucking
war,
American flag pants and shirt.
There's a famous picture of him with a
beer on Misa patriot that a lot of ways
he wanted to be involved in the
political process.
He was very idealistic,
is he was probably shattered by finding
out to the party that he was working for
was corrupting the democratic process.
And because I've said this before,
you know,
I've been accused of helping Donald
Trump win by really wacky people online.
They're like pointing out all the flaws
of Hillary Clinton.
Like,
look,
man,
you can't ignore that shit because you
want one side to.
When I've talked about all of his flaws
to it,
there's a lot of flawed human beings are
run for president.
Pretty much all of them.
I mean,
it's very rare.
We have someone's not flawed,
right?
Extremely flawed.
We're all flawed,
but extremely flawed.
Who wants to be the fucking King of the
world?
It's very rare.
Well,
uh,
you know,
not to change subjects,
but Barack Obama,
everyone thinks is the greatest guy in
the world.
Do you know,
in contrast to Donald Trump?
Because he was polite,
he was a statesman,
he was a good speaker website.
But at the end when he was polite at the
same time,
he let cops correct the heads of
peaceful protesters at occupy Wall
Street all across the country,
said he put on a soft shoe to stand up
for unions.
He fucked over unions in Wisconsin when
they took the teacher's union a way,
uh,
he opened the Arctic to drilling twice
whenever shell oil wanted.
He said,
okay.
And he only closed it when they didn't
want to do it anymore.
He took us from two wars to seven.
He cooked out five point 1 million
families out of their homes instead of
helping them.
And he made Wall Street whole while
fucking over everybody else.
So this guy,
he ended,
he made the Bush tax cuts permanent.
So there was a,
what they say is,
uh,
it looked like it was changed on the
outside continuity on the inside,
just completely through the windshield.
That's a negative way.
Is this the flat Earth Guy?
Oh,
that guy is crazy.
He's only raised $110 because we need to
know math.
Hold on.
It's only $110 at a $10,000 goal.
Listening flat earthers.
You need to put your money where your
mouth is.
I'm starting to believe that you don't
really believe in this cause.
Yeah,
send my boy Michael Hughes.
$10,000 and you get your liver spotted.
Hands off.
My mother had a couple of shots at him.
He bailed on the fails,
right?
I don't think he's actually does.
He launched himself into space yet.
I think they got the late a few times.
The first time he's going to do it.
Then the government got involved and I
was like,
yeah,
you can't do that.
Know that is such a crazy move.
Rock doesn't fucking.
He has $10,000.
If Eddie,
you think there is fucking give this guy
some money,
but what about that?
Bob Character isn't even super wealthy.
There's funding a single forever because
he's been too busy with flat earth
theory.
Listen man,
once he understands the fucking real
true image of the earth,
and then you have a wall that surrounds
the outer realm of the earth and
everybody thinks is worth is round.
You got shit to tell the people.
It's more important than your rap song.
You made things run.
You got to get people.
Whoa.
Look at the guy from Brinkley to when
it's moved on,
he moved on.
Y'All got to take this flat earth shit
to the next level.
Fuck the flat versus round argument.
Let's talk more about the simulation and
who's programming it is.
That's how both sides get benefit.
If it's round or flat.
Oh my gosh is crazy.
He's going through some shit.
It's flatter stuff.
What else can we tell?
Well,
here's the thing,
and this is something really important
for anybody who's listening to this.
You've got to not hang yourself on your
ideas.
I've done it.
I did in the past.
When you do that,
you're not really paying attention.
You're only looking for things that
support your idea.
It's called confirmation bias.
Everybody,
if everybody is susceptible to it,
me included,
have.
I've done it 100 times to myself when
the task,
but once you realize what it is,
if you keep doing the same goddamn
thing,
then you're being stupid.
So once you know what it is and you know
it's possible,
we'll do.
Let's just look at this.
Look at all the overwhelming amount of
evidence from super geniuses that say
it's around just you gotta walk away,
it's it hurts you.
It hurts your view of the world to
believe that because you can't believe
it if you're really paying attention.
So if you believe that what you're
saying is you have a very limited box in
which you're willing to operate in.
You're not willing to accept anything
outside of what you've already got as a
preconceived idea and you're ignoring
massive amounts of data that points to
the fact that you're wrong.
So by doing that,
you limit your own view of yourself,
you,
you become you.
You don't trust in the way you view
things anymore.
Your box.
Then it's very dangerous to be committed
to something you know is not true.
It also shows a level of diligence to
because when you got these geniuses who
spent their entire lives doing doing
this stuff and astrophysics,
you're telling me that third part of
this scheme to and they believe that
it's 100 percent of the problem.
One hundred percent.
It's adopting an idea too soon.
That's 100 percent of the idea because
once you.
Once you adopt that idea and then you
hang onto it,
now you're fucked.
Like bigfoot.
Bigfoot was a big one for me.
I was.
I was convinced it was real with you.
How long ago was this?
A couple weeks when it
drops.
Oh yeah,
that's totally legit.
No,
dude,
if you can get a guy into that position,
that shit will hurt.
Yup.
If you get a guy like Gordon Ryan puts
you in something like that.
Just for fun.
Yeah,
I'll fuck your legs up,
but here's a go back to it again.
I don't think it's a good position for a
couple reasons,
so like right there.
It's good if you can get to that,
if you can get to that,
but I'm sure.
Here's the catch dop in him.
I'm not sure what stopping him from
scooting his butt towards that guy's
right leg.
Here's the catch is that if you can roll
over while you're in the figure four leg
lock,
it completely reverses the polars of
the,
uh,
of the,
earth pain of the pain.
So then Rick flair with.
Well,
let me see it again.
By the way,
that's also true in real life.
I've tested that.
Well,
what I'm saying is like the position
you would,
there's a natural way to defend it that
it doesn't seem like the guys defending
it.
That's why like,
look.
Oh,
he's trying to keep them from putting it
in there.
Oh,
he stepped on his dick because he's
stepping on his deck a little bit.
That's the undertaker.
You're allowed to.
Okay.
This is a short legs down.
Oh yeah,
that's a heel hook.
Yeah.
Okay.
The guy.
Here's the why.
This is so fucking stupid.
The guy who's getting his leg kranked is
actually the guy who's in the best
position.
He's in a heel hook position.
Yeah.
If you could just grab his leg.
Right.
So who's supposed to be getting hurt
here?
This is actually the guy in black.
The guy in black is.
No,
no.
The guy in the better position.
All he has to do is reach back with his
right arm and hook,
timeout,
elbow onto the ankle.
No,
you time out,
motherfucker.
This is not a figure four leg lock.
This is embarrassing.
That's a heel hook.
He's given them a heel hook and the
other guys pretending he's in pain.
This is crazy.
This isn't even a figure.
Four leg lock to know what this is.
It's an unmodified.
Oh,
come on.
Lucky's in agony.
No,
he's got a fucking heel hook.
Take the heel.
Look.
It's right there.
You go like this.
You clap your hands together.
The match is over.
I mean it's 100 percent over in real
life.
Yeah.
Well,
what the fuck are they doing that?
What did they do at winners or losers?
Everybody gets a trophy.
Is that what you're doing?
You show in a terrible position.
The guy in white isn't trouble.
What happened?
Oh,
I broke up.
Yeah,
the other guys doing it wrong for the
whole fucking time.